et selon les dernières informations le
quartier des Troyes China au nord-est de
Kiev de l'autre côté du fleuve ni pro
est toujours sans électricité selon le
porte-parole des forces aériennes
ukrainiennes yuriacnat ce n'était pas
des drones ce matin mais tes missile
tiré par des avions et les avions qui
partiraient non pas de la mer Caspienne
comme c'était souvent le cas avant mais
de la région de Rostov en Russie tout
près de la frontière ukrainienne ce qui
donne moins de temps au système de
défense antérien
ukrainien de réagir parce que le temps
de vol des missiles et d'autantoindre et
alors il y a eu trois requêtes qui ont
atteint leur cible à Kiev ce matin et
puis il y a aussi les villes de gitomir
et de ni pro j'étais à l'ouest Kiev ni
pro à l'Est qui ont été frappés aussi
toujours des infrastructures de
génération d'électricité et une grande
partie des villes de ni pro et des
zitomir est actuellement sans
électricité la compagnie détecte l'une
des majeures compagnies des générations
d'électricité en Ukraine pour sa part
dit que deux de ces centrales sont très
sévèrement endommagés ils ont dit que il
est difficile de voir comment ils vont
pouvoir les mettre en marche pour le
moment ce sont les réseaux de secours
qui fonctionnent qui fait que sur la
plupart du pays il y a l'électricité
mais le président voulait dire Zelinski
a dit que 30% des centrales électriques
du pays en ce moment sont endommagés